hello and welcome to another Bitcoin
protocol tutorial video in this video
we're gonna be discussing the combining
and splitting values section of the
paper
this section is mostly just here to
clear up what some people might be
worrying about and that's how do we
handle varying amounts of Bitcoin that
are transacted up to now it's really
only been discussed in the idea of like
a full coin each time and obviously we
can split up a Bitcoin and trade
multiple at a time and that's part of
what makes it so great is that it's very
well divisible so hitting the paper
although would be possible to handle
coins individually it would be unwieldly
to make a separate transaction for every
cent in a transfer to allow value to be
split and combined transactions contain
multiple inputs and outputs normally
there will either be a single input from
a larger previous transaction or
multiple inputs combining smaller
amounts and at most two outputs one for
the payment and one returning the change
if any back to the sender it should be
noted that fan-out where a transaction
depends on several transactions and
those transactions depend on many more
is not a problem here there is never a
need to extract a complete standalone
copy of a transactions history so this
section is basically here to just
quickly dispel any fears about how the
system might be worthless since you can
easily since you wouldn't be able to
easily combine or divide a payment the
idea here is that you can have multiple
inputs for a transaction and you're
usually having two Max outputs the idea
here is that everything is quickly
cleaned up in a nice fancy way so to
track a payment you you wouldn't have to
figure out where that money fully came
from since you could consider this like
in exchange where when you buy one
Bitcoin you might get point two from a
person point five from another and point
three from another after that you might
only sell point seven etc so naturally
as time went on and that you know let's
say you sold point seven to a guy who's
buying a full one Bitcoin as well he
gets point seven from you point two from
another guy and point one from another
guy right
so obviously that would get really
really messy really quick and you can
see how it might be required that you
have a
full you know transaction history in
order to keep up with this stuff
so anyway not the case but yeah so not
not too much here just basically
dispelling that so anyway we're gonna
move on to the next section and that's
privacy as always thanks for watching